when this person switches in and out of
personalities usually has to do with
like some type of flashing bright light
or whatever and I see that element being
abused here that's just gonna be a
really fun scene it's gonna be like a
compilation put together well you know
like celebrity impressions
you know alleviate all the gripes from
people who during the scene of this
personality so there were 23 other so
like 623 there's at least one in there I
didn't recognize me before play some
quirky ass music hey reject nation Greg
Gallagher Donald's so we are gonna do a
review now for the glass trailer and a
little experimentation here if you
didn't see our reaction can go ahead
check that out link in the description
box and whatnot the meantime let's let's
move on to right where we are I can't
tell if the trailer reveals it's too
much or if the trailer just put in a lot
of things in different orders of because
at the end of split David Dunne is
learning who learns who he is and then
he bumps into him they have that scene
that you see in the last row too and it
looks like that in there he's hunting
him down and then what I'm think is the
way the event the trailer makes a play
out is that they break out and they're
fighting each other that's when he has
to kidnap girls
yeah and David Dunn shows up to save the
day but I haven't feeling that's all
gonna take place before they go into the
place yeah because she says I mean she
says that thing about like you got two
new friends joining you and stuff like
that so yeah yeah that really makes me
wonder if especially some of the like
more sinister Kevin's like it seems like
you know when he's like galloping on all
fours and stuff that seems like a later
on in the movie kind of yeah and but
when yeah he's got the cheerleaders and
all that there's so much more action in
this trailer than there is in any of
split so much strength on display here
the amount of
machine picking up stuff breaking stuff
yeah there's a lot of action in here if
any one of the three films earns the
right to do that it's this one also I
like how this trailer was very Samuel
Jackson glass Center the big excitement
has been David Dunn and Kevin going up
against each other
yeah and then glass is kind of in the
center of it all but this one really
shows that he's the mastermind and it
kind of makes you wonder is this some
type of plan he's sort of been working
up his sleeve
you know I'm breakable he's obviously
sentence it seems like this could be
something that was sort of in the works
they even had that image where he's
looking through the comic the Beast
because in the first unbreakable movie
what all the information you learned the
guy is a mastermind and a comic book
expert you know what the two together
you got a perfect real-life yeah his
motivations for you know breaking them
out are a bit more than just I want to
do evil stuff it's like you know the
world is going to recognize us yeah
we're going to make a spectacle of this
to get people's attention exactly
exactly and I don't know much about the
ID this is you have identity disorder
I'm not an expert I didn't take a
psychology course I did but I asked for
this trade I have been watching Iron
Fist Season 2 which has a character that
suffers from di D similarly like like
when this person switches in and out of
personalities usually has to do with
like some type of flashing bright light
or whatever and I see that element being
abused here that's just gonna be a
really fun scene it's gonna be like a
compilation put together well you like
celebrity impressions yeah you know
alleviate all the gripes from people who
would during split like I didn't see
enough of this personality so there were
23 yeah they're so like 623 there's at
least one in there I didn't recognize
her before I didn't play some quirky ask
music one is I think that's the same
woman who played Sam Jackson's mom in
the first one I like how she has that
light in there she's like they never
they always underestimate the mastermind
yeah yeah she's always been someone who
felt that her son was misunderstood and
had to look out for him because he was
born with this condition
where his body's made of glass glass
bones of paper skin yeah
every morning I break my legs and every
evening I break both my heart you know
weird way it seems like she's kind of
rooting for him to win well and that
lines very obvious they break out yeah
interesting one because I can't tell I
think you touched on this earlier in the
video like I can't tell how revealing or
not this is but one thing that makes me
hope it's not overly revealing is that
lion actually because movies called lash
this is never under like people always
underestimate the mastermind so I'm
hoping that there's something to this
more than just you know the breakout in
the ultimate fight you know yeah and is
Shyamalan you know he always goes for
some kind of twist I'm sure there'll be
plenty of surprises yeah I'm hoping that
you know like the word grounded is kind
of thrown around a little loosely these
days and I'm kind of hoping because
there's a lot of more action in this
trailer and I expected there to be for
some reason the one thing I didn't
really anticipate for this movie was
actually okay it's not like who's one
it's like yeah break won't split don't
really have action in there but it would
make sense of there's action here I'm
hoping that M night Shyamalan sticks
true to like every action moment being
well justified and having the kind of an
emotional stakes as opposed to I'm
making a cool comic book yeah yeah
because I'm breakable and split are in
this universe of you know glasses
mindset the comic book characters are
real people with supernatural abilities
are real but the movies don't feel like
a comic book work this trailer that felt
more like a comic book than the last one
did yeah and I yeah the word grounded
does get thrown around a lot but I do
feel like this is a good series to use
that with because it seems like it takes
place in a more human version of the
world a world where even if the physics
are heightened by their powers and
whatnot the most outlandish thing I saw
in this trailer is when he's crawling up
the walls you know and so I'm hoping
that yeah it doesn't get too big I just
hope it doesn't become beasts versing
David gun and a brawl throughout a movie
era Hawaii and I'm like you know what
made those two movies so great was the
character studies of both characters I
wouldn't want to lose that
and his end as well
Sam Jackson's glass yeah and I wouldn't
want to lose any of that you know the
fun of him switching in and out of
personalities will that really affect
the way the plot is playing out in this
movie or is he just know he snowed for
most of it you know that's yeah that's
kind of my one suspicion about it I mean
I really just hope this is glasses movie
like to justify like you know that's
gonna be all three of their movie in a
sense but I do hope the glass is the Sun
and I think this trailer really went out
of its way in its first like thirty
Seconds to really show that no this is
gonna be him at the center him leading
this thing so if my prediction is he'll
get his wish by the end I imagine he'll
die but I think he'll also be rewarded
with the world learning the truth now
he's just gonna ride around on Kevin's
shoulders forever and they're gonna be
the perfect super villain if anybody
knows After Effects or Photoshop out
there make it happen turn it into a gif
and I would be satisfied the one thing
that I haven't gotten from either of
these trailers yet that I'm very curious
about is what on you Taylor Joy's
involvement is gonna because I know that
like in the first movie they did at
least hint that she has abilities too
and they keep showing her in these
prominent moments and I'm sitting here
going whoa what's her deal yeah I kind
of afraid that that's what's gonna
happen but I don't know they just spent
so much time developing that character
do something I just don't know what it
was gonna be and I feel like that's
where the big surprise is probably gonna
be ahead of us I feel like Sam Jackson's
gonna die and I feel like I know Taylor
Joy's gonna play a bigger part then the
trailers are leading us to bleep right
now they're selling us some all the hype
and everything and like we've touched on
before how we think like oh maybe the
trailers are misleading us in some
fashion in terms of how the structure
the film's gonna go how the plots gonna
play out I think that they're doing a
great job at hiding on you Taylor Joy's
performance and I feel like Sarah
Paulsen maybe her herself has some type
of abilities as well you know even
though she's set up as this doctor who's
like I specialize in people who think
they have you know superhero abilities I
think that there's something up maybe
yeah laughs in a way where she's got
something special about her she's like
no one's gonna buy this yeah she's the
Nick Fury of this to get you all
together a couple of our things heard
that David Dunn's kid is supposed to
return for this one as well he's nowhere
in this trailer they're going to
recreate the weightlifting scene he has
to finally train to go out and also the
music in this trailer is great I think
James Newton Howard I know that that is
true confident yeah I believe he did the
music for the first time breakable movie
and I think people really love that
soundtrack and I'm wondering if he came
back for this one I'd be pretty good I
don't remember the music all that well
but some of this sounded like him the
unbreakable - yeah it definitely has a
similar earmark and it seems like
they've been able to bring back so many
of the people you know over so much time
from these you know previous to me yes I
would not put it past him to have that
you know I imagine that's probably a lot
of jokes and the comment boxes for this
trailer
oh yeah and Professor X like everybody
has a superhero across multiple
franchises across multiple way do this
man you know try on a new hat
hire prey and Professor X either
depressed or happy will here play 23
different folks all right guys well
thanks for watching along here are you
excited for glass do you have any of the
same concerns or do you have no concerns
have AZ all your faith in Shyamalan been
restored air-beds of one okay movie in
one great movie you guys can subscribe
to the rejection please click that
notification balcon subscribe buttons
don't do the trick as much as they used
to and you can check us on patreon TV
show reactions Q&A as we'd love to have
you become a big project